spoons
cardboard boxes toddler size electric
trains holiday ornaments bounce houses
blankets baskets carpets tray tables
smartphones pianos robes photographs
what do all of these things have in
common aside from that there are photos
that I took in the last three months and
therefore own the copyright to their all
inventions that were created with the
benefit of language none of these things
would have existed without language
imagine creating any one of those things
or like building an entire building like
this without being able to use language
or without benefiting from any knowledge
that was got by the use of language
basically languages the most important
thing in the entire world
all of our civilization rests upon it
and those who devote their lives to
studying it both how language emerge
what how human languages differ how they
differ from animal communication systems
or linguists formal linguistics is a
relatively young field you know more or
less and it's uncovered a lot of really
important stuff like for example that
human communication systems differ
crucially from animal communication
systems that all languages are equally
expressive even if they do it in
different ways and yet despite this
there are a lot of people who just love
to pop off about language like they have
an equal understanding of it as a
linguist because of course they speak a
language and if you speak a language
that means you have just as right to
talk about its function as anybody else
imagine like if you're talking to a
surgeon and you say eh listen buddy I've
had a heart for like forty years now I
think I know a thing or two about aortic
valve replacements I think my opinion is
just as valid as yours and yet that's
exactly what happens this is Neil
deGrasse Tyson saying that in the film
arrival he would have brought a
cryptographer somebody who can
unscramble a message in a language they
already know rad
than a linguist to communicate with the
aliens because what would a linguist you
know why would that be useful in talking
to somebody speaking of the language we
don't even know of course the arrival
film is not off the hook I mean come on
listen film hey buddy there are aliens
that come down to our planet and
gigantic ships and they want to do
nothing except for communicate with us
and you hire one linguist was a US
government on a budget or something
anyway so um a lot of these things can
be chalked up to misunderstandings both
about what language is and about the
formal study of language about
linguistics and I think that there's
something that underlies a lot of these
misunderstandings that can be summed up
by this delightful article in Forbes
about why high school students shouldn't
learn foreign languages I'm going to
pull out some quotes from this and I
want you to see if you can figure out
what underlies some of these opinions
and ideas Americans rarely read the
classics even in translation so in other
words why bother learning in a foreign
language when they're not even going to
read the classic in the original anyway
what's the point
study in foreign languages in school is
a waste of time compared to other things
that you could be doing in school Europe
has a lot of language groups clustered
in a relatively small space so for
Americans ah what's the point of
learning another language you're not
really going to get a lot of bang for
your buck out of that this is my
favorite a student in Birmingham would
have to travel about a thousand miles to
get to the Mexican border and even then
there would be enough people who speak
English to get around so in other words
if you can kind of wave your arms around
and you can get to where you're going
then there's really no point in learning
another language anyway what underlies a
lot of these attitudes is the conceptual
metaphor language is a tool and there's
something that rings very true about
this metaphor language is kind of a tool
and that if you know the local language
you can do more than if you didn't but
the implication is that language is only
a tool and this is absolutely false
if language was a tool it would honestly
be a pretty poor tool and we would have
abandoned it long ago for something that
was a lot better I'll give you an
example think about
any sentence here's a sentence that I'm
sure I've said in my life yesterday I
saw can I have a friend named Ken and
when I say this why say this sentence
yesterday I saw Ken do you think it's
really the case that everything in my
mind is now implanted in your mind via
this sentence hardly because there's a
lot of other stuff going on like when I
say yesterday and I think what the
weather was like yesterday because I was
there and if I'm remembering now I'll
probably remember that there was
something I forgot to mail which I did
actually this is funny this was a
pre-planned joke but I really did forget
to mail something and so that means I'm
gonna have to do it Monday as opposed to
because that's what I'm gonna get back
home and then of course if I when I
think of Monday I'll think of Manic
Monday by the bangles it's a it's a good
song and when I say the word saw I think
of this phrase I see said the blind man
as he picked up his hammer and saw I
always do any time I hear the word saw
or say it I always think of that because
my grandfather always used to say it's
that makes me think of my grandfather
and we're back to Manic Monday again for
some reason and with Ken when I'm
talking when I'm saying something like
yesterday I saw Ken I will consider I'll
think of the circumstances under which I
saw him and this happened to be that day
here he is with my cat and of course if
I'm thinking of Ken then I'll think that
he's going to Long Beach State right now
and I will remember that my good friend
John and my mother both graduated from
Long Beach State my cousin katie is
going to Long Beach State right now in
semantics Monday again but really like
this is just a fraction of what's going
on in your head at any given time while
you were speaking and all we have to
represent the entire mess that is going
on in our head and is this I mean that's
all we got is it any wonder that our our
system is so far so imagine if I can
give you an analogy imagine like if and
if you wanted to know what does it like
to eat a cake if instead of just eating
the cake you instead had to ingest the
ingredients of a cake one by one along
with instructions about how these
ingredients can be combined to form a
cake you had to eat the instructions -
if that was how we had to experience
cake we would never eat cake and yet
language is the only way the only way
that we can figure out what is going on
here in our minds this is our interior
tea the thing that makes us human the
thing that makes us different
from other animals is all inside here
somewhere and all we have to do to
represent it is our own languages a
language is their best way of showing
what's going on in our head so imagine
if I want to ask a big question like
what is the nature of human thought and
emotion what you'd want to do is you'd
want to examine as many different
languages as possible one isn't just
going to do it
to give you an example here's a picture
I took of little Roman it's at that I
took with a 12 megapixel camera now
here's that same picture with a lot
fewer pixels obviously neither of these
pictures of pictures is a real cat but
one gives you a lot better sense of what
a cat is than the other the idea
language is not merely a tool it is our
legacy it's our way of conveying what it
means to be human and of course by our
by our legacy I mean all humans
everywhere and losing even one language
makes that picture a lot less clear so
as a as a job for the past 10 years and
also as recreation just for fun I create
languages these are called new conlangs
short for constructed languages now
presenting these facts back to back that
we're losing languages on our planet and
that I create brand new languages you
might think that there's some non
superficial connection between these two
in fact a lot of people have drawn a
line between those dots this is a guy
who got all bent out of shape that there
was a con laying in James Cameron's
Avatar he says but in the three years it
took James Cameron to get avatar to the
screen a language died probably a lot
more than that actually not BLS won't
fill the hole where it used to be a
truly profound and poignant statement if
you don't think about it at all but when
I was here at Cal I completed two majors
one of them was linguistics but the
other one was English and of course the
English major the study of English is
not actually the study of the English
language as we know it's the study of
literature literature is just a
wonderful thing because basically
literature more broadly is kind of like
art right it falls under the rubric of
art and what we do with literature
authors create new entire beings in
history's at the end a and it's
interesting to us to see what kind of
depth and emotion and and just unique
spirit authors can invest into these
fictional beings so much so that I mean
take a look a look at this
there's an entire series of books that
are written about fictional characters
like the entire book is just about one
fictional fake human being there's an
entire book on George F Babbitt from
Sinclair Lewis's Babbitt and I guarantee
you that book is longer than Babbitt
which is a short book and this anybody
even remember that one if it's pretty
good I actually think it's better than
Main Street that's that's my hot take
anyway the crazy thing about so we've
never questioned the fact that
literature is interesting but despite
the fact not even linguists are actually
interested in what created languages can
tell us about the depth of the human
spirit just as an artistic endeavor I'll
give you I'll give you a nice little
example here there was a there was an
article written on me about me in the
California alumni magazine a while back
and when they wrote this article they
wanted to get somebody from the opposing
side which in hindsight seems like a
weird thing to do and you're just
talking about a person and you want to
get somebody from the opposing side of
that person I mean essentially this is
just a puff piece but whatever anyway so
they happen to get one of the most
brilliant linguists of our time George
lekha fizeau linguist here at Berkeley
and his work is basically forever
changed the fields of linguistics and
cognitive science and when asked about
my work in about language creation in
general he said but there's a lot of
things to be done in the study of
language you should spend the time on
something real yeah something real does
this remind you of anything to use the
very framework that he himself invented
let me refer back to this conceptual
metaphor language is a tool he appears
to be laboring under this conceptual
metaphor that his languages useful when
it can be used for communication
language is useless when it can't be
used for communication I wonder make you
wonder what what do we do with dead
languages but anyway so because of this
idea it might seem like the very height
of absurdity to have a duolingo course
on the high Valyrian language that I
create
for HBO's Game of Thrones you might
wonder what exactly are seven hundred
and forty thousand people learning well
let's let's let's take a look at it what
are they learning what could they
possibly be learning well very in mind
that the other language for this it's
for people that speak English English
speakers are learning quite a bit here's
here's a sentence that they will
probably never use for communication in
their entire lives
voilá abre old earnest the man sees the
woman and the little middle line is the
gloss so it's word for word that's what
it says and they're actually learning
some very fascinating things especially
if they are English speakers they're
learning that a verb can come at the
very end of a sentence doesn't really do
that in English when you have two
arguments they're learning that there
isn't sometimes the language doesn't
have an equivalent for the word though
it's just totally absent that's
something language can do they're
learning that a long vowel can actually
be longer in duration as opposed to
differing in quality which is what our
long vowels do they're actually the same
length they're learning that there are
these little inflections mm-hmm
their inflections are called cases on
the in and outs that tell you who does
what to whom in a sentence even if you
leave the order of the words the same
and switch the endings it changes who
does what to whom what they're learning
is that languages do things the same
things differently and that learning
languages can be fun what they're
learning is respect for language capital
L language and given the fact that 88%
of Americans only speak English at home
I don't think that's necessarily a bad
thing you know
you know why languages die on our planet
it's not because the government imposes
a one language on a smaller group or
because an entire group of speakers is
wiped out that certainly has happened in
the past and it's happening now but it's
not the main reason the main reason is
that a child is born to a family that
speaks a language that is not widely
spoken in their community and that child
doesn't learn it why because that
language is not valued in their
community
the
the language isn't useful because the
child can't go and get a job if they
speak that language because if language
is just a tool then learning there lay
their native language is about as useful
as learning high Valyrian so why bother
now maybe language study isn't going to
lead to a lot more linguistic fluency
but maybe that's not such a big deal
maybe if more people are studying more
languages it will lead to more
linguistic tolerance and less linguistic
imperialism
maybe if we actually respect language
for what it is literally the greatest
invention in the history of humankind
then in the future we can celebrate
endangered languages as living languages
as opposed to museum pieces Green will
say thank you